hello Guardians the kvass tov has made
its way back this time in rise of iron
as an exotic first and foremost you'll
have to get the schematics for the kvass
off to trigger a request so that you can
get the gun you want I wasn't able to
test it but for those who have their
original cost off you might be able to
break it down to get the schematics
however for those like me that didn't
have it you'll have to go and hunt for
it firstly you'll need to acquire the
splicer inner relay drop I got mine from
a brood mother in the plague lands
patrol these brood mothers will drop
either a splicer key or a splicer inner
relay you might have already gotten one
and not noticed there's one that spawns
really close to the patrol on the left
that you can farm to get the splicer
inner relay once you get this splicer in
a relay drop it you can make your way to
find in the schematics for the cabassa
you're going to need to head to the
divide in order to do that you're going
to have to go through foundry 113 and
the rocket yard the moment you land in
the plague land patrol head straight and
slightly to the right head through these
corridors until you get to the foundry
113 pass through the foundry 11 threes
open area until you get through these
other corridors that will lead you to
the rocket yard once you get to the
rocket yard head on over to the divide
once you're at the divide head straight
and to the left until you get to this
hole in the wall head through here and
into the corridor and keep going through
the subsequent quarters until you reach
an open area you'll now reach a station
where you'll be asked to use a splicer
Intel relay head out towards the
beginning of the second mission where
the huge catch was once you head towards
the catch defeat all the opposition in
your way including a big servitor and
you'll find the schematics in the right
corner behind them once you've acquired
the schematics head back to shiro at the
fellow winners peak he'll give you a new
quest for the kvass tov to get three
parts and ten pages to form the gun one
of the three parts you need is located
at the spot where you got your first
ship in vanilla destiny again head to
the divide to get here the next two
parts you'll need to get will require
you to head through the rocket yard and
into the warehouse you would go through
for the septic strike you'll find the
first of the two parts in this corridor
area right after the waves of enemies
you would normally have to fight it's in
this corner the next weapon part is in
an area past 23 waves where the Fallen
Walker would usually be it's around the
first main building you'll see right
when you exit the corridor these weapon
parts will be found during the plague
land patrols and I don't think you'll be
able to get them during
strikes or story to get the 10 pages you
need just kill enemies and get 10 to
drop I got a good amount of them in the
divide area the final step is to do the
mission that Cheryl sends you on to
finally get the gun you'll have to chase
a captain who's cracked out on seba
you'll finally chase him again into a
familiar area once you dispatch of him
he'll drop the kvass stock you can then
proceed to use it to finish the rest of
the mission and also get a nice
heart-to-heart talk with your ghosts oh
man the fields have fun with your new
kvass tov Guardians and tell me what
your favorite mode of the kielbasa feels
I personally like the pulse style with a
nine hundred rpm it's pretty fun stay
tuned to gamespot com for continuing
coverage of Destiny's rise of iron